hey guys Pete here like a lot of people
I started watching this show Game of
Thrones before I had even heard of the
books in truth I probably would have
never read the books if it wasn't for
the show because fantasy other than the
Lord of the Rings just wasn't something
that I would go out and find I started
watching Game of Thrones when season two
was going on because a friend of mine
told me that he didn't think he would
like it when he heard what it was about
but once he started watching he couldn't
stop
I started binging at that point and
ended up catching up before the season 2
finale aired which was I know I watched
19 episodes in like 6 or 7 days ever
since then I've existed in this
continual waiting period for the next
episode so I decided to pick up the
books to read during the downtime this
will be a short video on why I think
everyone who likes the show should read
the Song of Ice and Fire series and it
will be spoiler free as possible I tried
not to include anything that gives away
storylines regardless of where you're at
in the show so unlike a lot of my other
videos you don't have to be caught up to
actually watch this I tried to go beyond
the most obvious reasons like reading is
good for you and that books are better
because I think we all kind of know
those things to be true there might be
some exceptions to the rule but I I
can't think of anything that was based
on a popular book that was better than
actually reading the book itself with
all that out of the way let's jump right
into number one now is the perfect time
since we know that season 7 is delayed
that it's going to be shorter with only
7 episodes and that season 8 which will
be the series final season will be
shorter still now is the time to start
reading remember the show has basically
already moved past most of the
storylines from the book so you won't be
spoiling anything if you are caught up
in the show you don't have to worry
about ruining the ending and in fact it
will actually happen in the show before
the last book will come out number 2 it
doesn't ruin the show for me the books
only made the show more interesting
there were things that didn't quite add
up that immediately made sense when I
read the books if you're worried that
reading the books might take the fun out
of watching the show I just can't really
see how that would happen there is a
faction of hardcore book readers who
freaked out about the show and sort of
live to bash it but if you already are a
fan of the TV show you can easily look
at them as two different things
as mentioned the books are better
is almost always the case but the show
is actually really good at some things
too everything you like about the show
is in the books and you get everything
else that is on this list as a bonus
number three point of view chapters the
first thing I noticed that I really
liked about the song and ice of hire
books compared to the TV show Game of
Thrones was that the chapters are all
written from the point of view of
different characters for example you
have bran Tyrion Ned Catelyn Daenerys
chapters and so on instead of an
all-knowing narrator who tells us what's
happening we hear the story from the
different characters perspectives and we
hear their thoughts along the way number
four more characters as the Game of
Thrones TV show goes on and it reaches
its series finale the showrunners have
had to cut some storytelling corners
this is understandable so I'm not going
to write it to like whine about it but
one of the things that happens is that
they choose to merge storylines together
so a character we see on the show might
be based on two or three from the books
which is not as good for obvious reasons
if you think the characters are
interesting on the show trust me they
are just as cool and there are a lot
more of them in the books plus beyond
the characters you don't know the ones
you do know are much more complex in the
books some of my favourite characters
from the books are barely in the show or
not in it at all number five history the
first thing I realized when I went back
to rewatch the show's after reading the
books was just how much I didn't
understand the historical significance
of anything that was going on now you
might think this is a fantasy show that
is entirely made up so that doesn't
matter but what's really insane is that
the history of Westeros itself goes back
a thousand years there's a large amount
of references to an event or a character
from the past that drives what's going
on at the moment and the history is
expertly woven into everything there is
even a giant book called the world of
Ice and Fire that outlines most
everything that happened in this world
before the events of the books and the
TV show george RR martin pulls a lot
from real world history as well so at
times the books almost read like
historical fiction think about house
histories with sigils and words lines of
succession for centuries of rulers and
detailed maps for most of a planet
number six scale Game of Thrones
probably has one of the largest budgets
of any TV show in history at this point
and they do a really good job
even so there are so many things they
have they just have to leave out budget
constraints will always lose out to your
imagination and the scale this world
george RR martin built is massive number
seven theories since we get the story
from the point of view of different
characters who themselves have
incomplete information we end up with a
lot to try to figure out a bunch of the
big mysteries can be solved with the
information provided and there's a huge
culture of people who break every little
detail down on sites like Westeros org
Reddit and obviously a bunch of YouTube
creators as well the amount of different
theories that grow up around the stories
and the books and what might happen in
the next one is so huge I can't really
think of anything to compare it to I
mean obviously you have like the Star
Wars universe and things like that but
it's just as big number eight plots
magic and religion these are three items
that just don't come off as well in the
show and the books the bad guys have
reasons for what they do and the depth
of their plotting is much more
interesting in the books
this goes for magic and religion as well
remember that magic actually is a part
of the world the story is set in and
just like our world different cultures
have created their own religions to help
understand why things are the way they
are it's really hard not to get spoilery
here so I'm just gonna have to leave it
at that
number nine dreams dreams play a big
part in the Song of Ice and Fire
and a lot of the main characters have
them again it's hard not to spoil the
books here so I won't get too far into
it I'll just say that if you've ever had
a dream that you wondered about or a
friend of yours told you about one and
you were just wondering what it meant
then you should probably go start
reading the books right now
number 10 george RR martin obviously it
all starts and ends with george RR
martin so of course he would be the top
reason on the list Westeros and the
world of Ice and Fire wouldn't exist
without him and all the other things on
this list are what he gave us his
writing is legitimately good and
presented in a way that you have to keep
going or you or you can't wait to get
back to it and the character creation is
on par with any of my other favorite
authors regardless of you know John Rowe
I think what he does well is makes great
characters that exist in this grey area
between good and bad the characters live
in a fantasy universe that's a lot like
our medieval world but they have
strengths weaknesses and
missions flaws and struggles just like
we do no one's 100% good and I think
it's likely that no one is truly pure
evil either the characters we like for
heroes aren't always safe or guaranteed
to win out at the end and there's also a
really good chance that what drives the
story is a commentary that's bigger than
just who ends up sitting on the Iron
Throne that's the top ten reasons I can
think of so I hope that gives you
something to think about if you've been
on the fence about reading the books
there really are so many reasons that I
can't mention because of spoilers and I
guess it wouldn't be right to not look
at some of the reasons why you might not
want to read the books either only the
thing the only one I can really think of
though is that it's a it's a pretty big
investment of time to date only five of
the planned seven books have been
released and it's already about four
times as long as the Lord of the Rings
trilogy
none of these are books that you could
read in one or two days but I never
found myself lowering the time that I
spent reading them back they're easy to
find an audiobook form too so if reading
isn't your thing or you have the long
commute to work each day that could be
an option as well let me know in the
comments have you been thinking about
reading them and just having taken the
plunge yet if you're like me and started
reading them after you got into the show
did you have a similar experience to
mine if you want to talk about major
plot points or characters that you like
better in the books that's fine but
let's add spoiler tags down there so we
don't ruin this for anybody else who
hasn't read while we're nerd now please
like this video if you found it
interesting and subscribe to my channel
for more game of Thrones and strong
advice and fire videos thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon